ils étaient plus de 350 spectateurs au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour la soirée de lancement du projet de
territoire le but améliorer la vie des
saint quentinois un projet auquel les
habitants pourront participer je pense
qu'on sera plutôt en information directe
avec des ateliers des tables rondes
pourquoi pas des séminaires des
rencontres véritablement en lien direct
avec la population et avec les
partenaires moi je serais ravi de
rencontrer les entreprises et puis aussi
l'université et pourquoi pas les
associations tout ça aussi en lien et en
partenariat avec le codes skis le projet
de territoire a pour objectif
d'améliorer les transports les logements
la circulation ou encore le bien-être
des saint quentinois pour y arriver les
douze communes de l'agglomération
doivent travailler ensemble nous étions
sept avants pas forcément aussi avec les
mêmes appartenance politique en tout cas
je crois que ce qui est bien ensuite
c'est que justement savez c'est la somme
de ces différences qui font que ensuite
on peut bâtir quelque chose de tout à
fait cohérent l'événement s'est déroulé
en présence de pierre bédier le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines il salue l'initiative nous
sommes-nous très favorable à ce projet
de territoire parce que saint quentin
c'est une formidable réussite sur les 50
dernières années c'est incontestable
c'est sans doute les experts le disent
les observateurs la ville nouvelle la
plus réussie de toutes les villes
nouvelles mais elle correspond à un
modèle d'autrefois le modèle d'autrefois
qui était le modèle de l'exode rural où
il fallait organiser la ville désormais
la ville elle est à peu prêt à organiser
mais surtout la ville avait tant
compétition est devenue métropole et
elle est en compétition avec les autres
métropoles unis avec le projet de
territoire saint quentin en yvelines
prépare son avenir durant l'année
plusieurs réunions seront organisées
dans les communes saint-quentinoise si
vous souhaitez donner votre avis sur le
sujet rendez vous sur le site de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines